it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we expose the big cultural
stories of the day since i'm here we
have a special guest welcome comedian
and radio host host of the fox nation
special the feast of the seven fishes
are pal joe piscopo joe merry christmas
now i know this time of year you like to
belt out those christmas tunes in your
car but be warned joe an irish insurance
company has put together a list of the
most dangerous christmas tunes to listen
to while driving apparently the more
beats per minute a song has the more
prone it is to make a christmas crash
now joe with that in mind i want to run
through the top three with you first we
have a song i actually find quite
addictive and it's by a friend of mine
listening
[Music]
now joe how is that a dangerous song for
goodness sake
with that on the list jose feliciano was
on the list i mean that's dangerous did
they put that uh oh no that's ridiculous
that's ridiculous that you bob along
with that you bob alone no dangerous is
in a god of in a god of davita that's
dangerous you know i mean if you're if
you can listen to us
in
am i right raven you know yes
definitely now let me joe i'm going to
move on to number two we have this one
yeah okay
[Music]
with the amount of time that song is
played joe i'm surprised we're not all
piled up on the freeway
what's your guess for the number one
most dangerous song what would you say
is the most dangerous song of christmas
joe
well i think i cheated a little bit you
know not unlike high school uh raymond
uh no no no i uh
it's like it's gotta be uh fr was it
frosty was it frosty the snowman am i
behold the treacherous frosty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joe i think you'll agree with me i think
the most dangerous song of christmas is
the sinatra song christmas memories that
line when they say you know i i remember
all the the faces of the children who
now have children of their own because
i'm always crying at that point so
that's not one i want to hear on you you
are raymond that's what i love about you
man that's a bergman song i believe that
was beautiful for mr sinatra well done
my friend you're right on the money
gordon not frosty i love gene autry but
really i mean not dangerous just not
dangerous no no not day none of these
songs are dude this is i think it's a
silly study joe that brings us to
another debate laura and i have an
annual real versus fake christmas tree
debate well it turns out the younger
crowd is taking laura's side according
to survey surveyfromtrees.com
71 percent of millennials say having a
real tree
significantly affects their ability to
enjoy the holiday 84 would be upset with
their parents for switching to a fake
christmas tree joe where do you fall in
the great christmas tree debate
well i hope i don't offend you but you
know i speak to you from out in the
boondocks of new jersey where are we are
you ready for this raymond cut down our
own tree we cut down our tree i play
i go out
you go to like a tree farm you know and
there's like all these trees set up and
they go all right which one you're
picking out and then you have your kid
cut it down as you watch you know it's
not like you don't really you don't
really go with the axe like paul but
yeah my son michael would be you know
and then you bring it you bring it now
listen you bring it home it's got
spiders in it man you put it up that's a
that's a man's way to do you know all
right
come on i i just like to unpack it no
there's no vermin in the trees joe uh i
wonder how many of those millennials are
actually cleaning the needles and
watering the tree from mom and dad
finally i have to get your take on this
christmas tragedy there's a perennial
christmas tradition of children visiting
santa it's been practiced for
generations well now macy's has
announced that in new york santa's lap
has officially become santa's socially
distanced office in a statement macy
says guests will visit santa in his
office and will be seated opposite
santa's desk young children who are not
able to be seated will require an adult
to see them come on joe this is
ridiculous what kind of photo with santa
is that at the office
i know it's true but you know raymond
honestly
as a father i have five children and and
i got a small it's my small daughter i
to sit on some strange guy's lap with a
beard and a mask on is a little creepy
at this point so i mean you know and
that and what would you like for
christmas that burl lives that joe biden
whisper what would you like for
christmas a little creepy for me a
little creepy for me i mean you know so
i don't mind i don't mind the office
thing it may be a workshop not an office
desk maybe with the elbows around you
know a little real
there's no way i would let a biden santa
near my kid you know be sniffing the
hair but we'll leave it there joe merry
christmas to you we'll see you in the
new year